heerd react Michael Knowles hosted the
Michael noir show good morning it's such
a treat normally we see you out in Los
Angeles we're waking up at the to 3:00
in the morning good to have you're on
set this is a very serious story we
cannot possibly minimize I know these
bombs didn't go off it's still
terrorised people but the idea that
Democrats are immediately saying that
because they don't like the president's
rhetoric somehow he has incited as one
of the words I've used he's incited
violence that's right they actually were
blaming him before they ever caught the
guy before they saw any motivation CNN
was referring to the Trump targets as
though President Trump were mailing
these packages himself this is the
double standard when a Bernie bro shoots
up a congressional baseball game they
don't talk about the Sanders shooter but
when someone targets Democrats its
president Trump's fault the reason for
this is that when a left-wing lunatic
commits an act of violence it is
considered an aberration when a
right-wing lunatic does it it is
representative of the whole group I'll
give you a great example which is I
noticed a story on New York times.com
last night that was saying before he was
a suspect they said this this guy the
suspect Cesar was a Trump superfan back
in 2017 when there was an assassination
attempt on Steve Scalise so you
mentioned and other Republican lawmakers
at the baseball practice I don't
remember a whole series of stories
saying that the shooter the you know the
shooter who and ultimately died himself
was a was a Bernie bros you say or was a
Bernie superfan that's people just
separated it out and said you know he
was a crazy Bernie Sanders fan but they
didn't blame Bernie Sanders that's right
and he volunteered for the campaign but
when it comes to Trump either way it
happens whether it's violence on the
left or the right they blame Trump when
it's on the left they blame him for
inciting it and when it's left wingers
attacking right-wingers it's they blame
him for provoking it like he had it
coming you know the only thing that we
can focus on here I think the only
tangible aspect of this is how the
elected leaders respond and when the
mainstream Left is committing mob
violence in the street how do the
Democrats respond they encourage it all
the way up to Hillary Clinton when it's
the right what does president Trump - he
says in the harshest possible terms
this is unacceptable will prosecute you
to the fullest extent what about the
fact that as soon as these bombs emerged
several days ago Hillary Clinton said
down in Florida around a campaign event
we've got to bring civility back to the
to be about a week or so after she said
we should not be civil that's what she
said only a week or two ago let's not be
civil because we don't like Donald Trump
well being a left-winger means never
having to say you're sorry this is
especially true of the Clintons they're
trying to flip their rhetoric now after
weeks and weeks of calling for explicit
violence from the mainstream of their
supporters restaurants where Republicans
children's sleep certainly this isn't on
the right and I think voters will
acknowledge too soon see that react to
your point Maxine Waters is also saying
the last 24 hours
that the president is encouraging
violence okay didn't isn't she the
person who said the cabinet secretary
shouldn't be able to sleep they
shouldn't be able to have a meal in a
restaurant again they're being
hypocritical that's exactly right but
the media have been spinning this
narrative since long before they
identified this guy he clearly was a
loner he's got a long criminal history
he's a total lunatic we acknowledge that
but what the left has to grapple with is
the mainstream of their supporters so
going out and you recall about that
hypocrisy but on the other hand doesn't
the President as the president of the
United States have an opportunity here
to try and elevate the debate say okay
you guys have called me a Nazi and a
racist I'm not happy about that he
shouldn't be happy about it but does he
need a sentence after saying you know
let's all come together does he really
need to go after fake news in the next
sentence well I think he has to
challenge this media narrative that's
been building for a long time but it is
true Nixon can go to China president
from consetta king of this rhetoric he
can say we are gonna be better than this
we are going to show the way and lead
the way I think he's already doing that
so but but we can't unilaterally disarm
on the media right but you're saying
Nixon to go to China Trump can go to
fake news that's exactly what those
great super nice to see you